are you a smoker it is tough to be a
smoker in 2015 and now the UK is going
to try to make it even more difficult
they want to pass a law that would
basically remove all branding from
cigarettes so we've got an image of what
the new boxes would look like so
basically they're going to have the
warnings now we have these warnings here
in America too and this is all over the
world right now where they just show you
some really scary [ __ ] of what it can do
to your lungs and your mouth and your
teeth and your gums and all that and
then the brand name would just be on the
bottom but it wouldn't involve Joe the
camel there would be anything that looks
cool or interesting or anything like
that and now we've got a little bit more
info on the proposed bill under the
proposed regulations packets would have
to have mandatory colors the current
proposal shows a brown packet on the
outside which is white inside the brand
and product names are the only items of
the text that the company can add the
new packets would have health warnings
such as smoking damages your lungs
tobacco smoke contains over 70
substances known to cause cancer alright
so this isn't that different but it is
sort of the next step in this but the
part that I think is interesting about
this is we have done so much with
smoking it is so changed now we're here
in LA so I get it we're on the people
are a little more into health here a
little more conscious I never see anyone
smoking pretty much a couple people I
think my director smoked we don't see
that many we don't see that many people
smoking so do you think the people at
this point that want to smoke does this
going this much further do you think
this stops anybody it did in Australia
in Australia this was passed and this is
mimicking that law and they did the
whole like you know nondescript
packaging with the warnings and so
because a lot from the colorful boxes
and sterile that's my brand and if you
don't identify anymore with the kind of
marketing behind your brand it might not
feel as connected but in Australia they
did this and I think smoking went down
from like 15 percent to 12 percent well
it worked I mean that's why they're
doing it and the truth is I think the
government needs to do what they can but
at the same time we have agency I'm not
all about out long new drugs
I want to decriminalize the old drugs
that people are gonna smoke if they can
smoke but for sure and I used to be a
smoker I smoked for many many years and
it was very hard for me to quit now I
run every other day and
tell you that it's not uncommon for me
to be running in my neighborhood and
there's a dude on the corner smoking a
cigarette and like in my run I'm like
you know like I'm breathing like
cigarette air while I'm running yeah
there is a guy I kid you not that I play
basketball every Sunday and there's a
guy that we play with that literally
smokes in between game yeah and I cannot
believe it and then he's hacking up a
lung
like he's literally hacking up and
spitting on the side of the court while
we're playing and I haven't said
anything but I want to look at him be
like dude do you see the connection
perhaps he does and he's probably doing
he's doing the best thing honestly cuz
most smokers aren't active so the truth
is the more active you are the easier it
is for you to quit because you actually
get that negative feedback which a lot
of people don't have yeah when I was a
smoker and I was like I know I need to
quit but I don't feel the the negative
effects of smoking and until I do I'm
not gonna feel the motivation to quit
when I started to feel the negative
effects of smoking I was like holy [ __ ]
that's interesting so should we then
take all the regulations off cigarettes
let them make that make it as
carcinogenic or whatever as possible
then people maybe would feel it more and
never think kids are gonna smoke then
kids are yeah I mean that's the whole
reason behind like getting rid of you
know the camel and the bright coloring
anyway and yeah it's it's against the
law I think here to have flavored
cigarettes yeah cuz kids will want to
smoke yeah I think some regulation is
good I think that um that this is a
really extreme you know measure to take
but uh you know I'm for it like you said
I mean if the research proves that less
people will smoke because they identify
less with the brand and the pretty color
isn't it you know I think that's awesome
that's the Surgeon General's job like
that's the job of people in this or or
whatever the British equivalent of there
is that's the job of people in those
positions of powers to bring the public
as much knowledge as possible and so if
they say this warning maybe it's
something people don't know or maybe
they just you need that cognitive do you
need to force it like I want to see it
every time I pick up the cigarette I
want to see that disease long yeah but
just wait back to play devil's advocate
like what if they start doing that with
like fast food you know they should they
should yeah you're easy world yeah right
so that's that's calorie counts down now
right so that's the slippery slope and I
remember when I lived in New York City
and they were putting calorie counts on
all the restaurants and there were
restaurants it was something like if you
had more than six locations in
Manhattan or something you had to do it
so there were some restaurants that
actually closed locations so that they
wouldn't have to put the calorie I know
nobody would want to buy their 7,000
calories right but even something like
Olive Garden in New York City had to
start putting the calories and I would
go and I'd see that you know like this
like fettuccine alfredo was something
like 4,000 calories don't quote me on
that exactly but that literally you're
having almost double the amount of
calories to get in a day so some of this
stuff does actually so it does yeah but
I am but as a general rule I'm leery of
like not too much government oversight
but there's a difference between Bannock
you know banning you know a large soda
in New York City is totally different
than putting information is giving me
information yeah I don't see anything
wrong with that yeah so last thought on
this you guys surprised the e-cigarettes
are working like it's actually working
you know we don't have advertisements
you can't have commercials regular
cigarettes but there are shitload of
commercials for anything and Jenny
McCarthy thank you for bringing that up
Jenny McCarthy who you know is
completely against vaccines but somehow
she has no problem doing I think it's
blue cigarettes or whatever that
e-cigarette thing is so is that sort of
the disheartening part of this like
we've done so much good with getting
people to stop smoking cigarettes but
we've just now shifted them into
something like that's what's gonna
happen always there's gonna be a profit
profit motive and it's gonna be co-opted
in order to make money and that's what's
so dangerous see cigarettes are almost
equivalent ly dangerous as dangerous as
regular cigarettes they're very very bad
for you and I totally understand them as
a tool to help quit because the nice
thing about e-cigarettes is you can
calibrate how much nicotine is in them
so you start with a full cigarette you
can go down to half the nicotine go down
to a quarter of the nicotine and
eventually just be smoking non nicotine
right and I'd get all out of it yeah but
I wonder how many people are exactly and
that's the sad thing this could have
been a really good therapeutic tool but
instead people are just smoking
e-cigarettes now instead of regular
cigarettes and none of the regulations
are in place yeah alright what do you
think do you smoke are we government
agents that are trying to control how
many calories and how much caffeine and
tobacco and all that stuff you put in
your body let us know in the comments
right down below